姐姐，
婆媳关系如何自处？
老公还可以挣钱也干活，
婆婆事儿多，
婆婆带孩子，
哎呦，
这事儿啊，
就千古难题呀，
婆婆要跟你生活在一起，
婆婆要帮你带孩子的话，
首先从心理上来说的话，
还是得感恩呗，
感谢，
真的，
你要让她感受到你对她带孩子的付出，
你是看在眼里的，
你是感谢她的，
感恩她的，
没事儿就嘴巴甜一点啊，
经常说，
你看哈，
别的婆婆都去打麻将了，
我的婆婆还在帮我带孩子呢，
我怎么运气这么好呢？
孩子怎么运气这么好呢？
遇到这么好的奶奶呢？
你给她捧的高高的，
让她心里情绪价值拉满，
确实是这样，
有的时候如果说经济条件咱们现在还暂时达不到，
说分开住也没有办法，
没有办法拒绝婆婆的帮助，
那婆婆在帮忙的时候的话，
我们作为儿媳妇就是情绪价值先给到未来，
除了情绪价值给到位之外，
你没事儿你得给她买点小礼物，
哎，
因为你要说真的，
你找一个人带娃的话，
六千八千起步，
贵的地方的话1万块钱，
也就是说她带娃那个价值是有经济市场衡量价值的。
我不知道我这么说待会儿就能不能接受啊，
有很多姐妹呢，
就是把婆婆帮我带娃当成是她应该尽的义务，
或者当成是她不认为是婆婆应该给我带娃，
其实实际上从法律上来说的话，
婆婆是没有义务帮我们带孩子的，
这是大实话啊，
我龙飞姐，
我翻遍了法条，
也没有哪条法律规定说婆婆必须要给我们带孩子，
那既然法律没有规定，
那么她给我带孩子的话，
就是一份恩情，
是一份情义，
嗯，
而且这份恩情还是有市场价值的，
市场价值的6000~1万吧，
没错吧，
6000~1万的市场价值，
那既然是这样的话，
你就想啊，
相当于是我占了婆婆6000~1万的一个月的这样一个便宜，
那是不是尊重上得给到位，
情感上情绪价值给到位，
呃，
如果情济条件允许的话哦，
你还是礼物上也得给到位，
红包上你不不说别的，
你红包你八百五百的你经常给啊，
婆婆过生日给个六百五百的啊，
婆婆就有，
母亲节到了，
你给个五百六百的啊，
咱就看自己的风景尤人啊，
你就让他掏不出毛病呗，
就这样子啊。